over a thousand years of history reside
in the friary of this church in Venice
sacked on over 80 kilometers of shelves
and map manuscript monographs documents
recording generations of Venetian
bureaucracy most of this vast collection
has never been read by modern historians
but a new project aims to uncover the
secrets of this enormous archive and
digitally reconstruct the Venice it
describes
the Venice time-machine project aims to
make the huge amount of data stored in
the State Archives of Venice accessible
to researchers
every page of paperwork must be scanned
and digitized to enable searching and
cross-referencing normal character
recognition software doesn't work well
on the wide variety of handwriting found
in the archive so machine learning is
being used to recognize word shapes and
match them between documents
cross-referencing names means
researchers can create social networks
for the city and the data contained in
maps enables them to recreate the
building up and occasional falling down
of Venice's buildings
information in maps can then be
cross-referenced with historical
paintings as well as modern photos and
combining these images with apparently
mundane paperwork about shops and
businesses means historians can
reconstruct the details of the city at
almost any point in its history this
virtual time machine should allow modern
historians and members of the public to
explore ancient Venice and the written
documents could provide datasets on
anything from trade and financial
markets to public health and the spread
of disease the technology developed for
the venice time machine project could be
applied to other ancient archives to
creating detailed and inspiring windows
into the past
[Music]